what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's up guys this is Edie from tech
source and today we are covering Green
Lantern vs. aliens
it's actually our indie comic stay but I
kind of feel like this would be fun cuz
I wanted to cover aliens but it's been
so long since we covered aliens I don't
know if anybody would watch it so I
figured let's bridge the gap and let's
do Green Lantern's first is aliens that
way we get like comic book superheroes
and aliens because I love xenomorph the
xenomorph comics are really really cool
now one thing I want you guys to keep in
mind is that because this is Green
Lantern's vs. aliens you're gonna see
some weird things they're gonna sort of
throw you off kilter in terms of the
fact that you're gonna be like that's
ridiculous no way a Green Lantern would
or would not be able to do that but it
does make for kind of an interesting
little bit of a story so initially this
opens up with just some unlucky Green
Lantern that's apparently implanted with
an embryo and of course an alien breaks
out of his chest and that's par for the
course whatever it comes to stories like
this it always opens up with somebody's
chest being busted open but at that
point it just kind of switches over to
your traditional fare of superhero
escapades on earth you've got Green
Arrow you got Black Canary they're
facing off against some you know
criminals that are there Green Lantern
Hal Jordan shows up he saves the day and
everything's done now in terms of the
whole superhero aspect and the Green
Lantern's really getting into the mix
this comes in with the guardians of the
universe
now something I want you guys to also
recognize here is that the first part of
this story that is to say this bit with
Hal Jordan of course takes place before
the events of Emerald Twilight when Hal
Jordan went crazy and declared himself
parallax and you know laid waste to the
entirety of the Green Lantern Corps we
don't know exactly when we just kind of
know that it does but him showing up on
this far off planet on the edge of space
or whatever it is really comes alongside
a handful of other guardians now of
course one of the things that DC really
always did with these you know when they
cross over with like I think other if it
was dark horse or IDW I want to say it
was dark horse but one of the things
that always happened you know regardless
of what it is is there's always some
measure of familiarity and that makes
sense because if you have Hal Jordan
here alongside great you know Green
Lantern's but you'd never seen or heard
of then it'd be kind of weird it seemed
a little strange but at this point in
time when they arrive on this planet
they basically end up finding out that
they're here because of the fact that
the Green Lantern of this sector had
basically just gone missing and so of
course this leads to the arrival of all
these different Xenomorphs pouring out
now this is what makes the story kind of
cool is because on the surface were like
okay so like when you watch aliens
it's the colonial Marines who are really
really cool they're the toughest folks
in the world until they meet the
xenomorph
they just get Rex left and right you
know that at the end of the day the only
thing that stands between these Marines
and death is whatever awesome guns they
happen to have and their wits with the
Green Lantern's they've got rings that
allow them to do virtually anything they
want to they can make any kind of
construct that they can think of and
then that's it I mean they they
basically have the upper hand on these
mindless beasts and so on and so forth
but the funny thing about this is that
the Xenomorphs are really really fast
and they're very hard to track and so
you know where we would normally think
this would be a super easy conflict no
muss no fuss and things would wrap up
very very fast ultimately these Green
Lantern's are almost easily taken by
surprise now the other half of this is
that where the response is let's destroy
them how Jordans answer is no we can't
and that's where things get a little
hairy that's one of those instances I
talked about where it's just kind of
like that wouldn't really happen under
normal circumstances virtually anybody
would have just been like yeah I agree
let's just wipe them all out but Hal
Jordan you know back in the days of him
when he was a Green Lantern before the
events of Emerald Twilight well he
wasn't necessarily like this you know
philanthropist humanitarian let's all
hold hands and sing Kumbaya what he did
believe in is the sanctity of life as
Green Lantern's they can't just go in
and obliterate every single threat they
come across because if they did there
would be no races left in existence and
so because of that the goal is to
basically mediate the threat remove it
from being a danger to the rest of the
universe and then call it a day and so
the response of Hal Jordan is to
basically round up all these xenomorph
and drop them off on the only place
where they can't harm anybody else the
planet Mogo with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to it now
they meet the Xenomorphs and they just
put it on another planet and that's the
end of the story piece that'd be so
disappointing I'd be so angry know what
it does is it basically shifts its focus
to after the events of Emerald Twilight
with Kyle Rader becoming the new Green
Lantern now for those of you guys who
were new and we've talked about this a
million times before
when I say emerald Twilight the the long
and short of that story is Hal Jordan
wasn't selling as the Green Lantern DC
wanted to get rid of them replaced him
with somebody new Hal Jordan wiped out
all the Green Lantern's and Kyle Rayner
was the only one to receive a ring the
only one left now the reason why that's
important is because this is where we
started to run into weird continuity
errors here one of the things you guys
notice is that how Raiders basically
grabbed by a handful of just
weird-looking
aliens one of these aliens is a guy by
the name
home are dark now this guy as far as I'm
aware doesn't exist I mean he's never
been seen in any other comics if he has
and I'm not familiar with him but
there's also characters here like salak
as far as I'm aware all these guys are
supposed to be dead the only Green
Lantern that should be alive is Kyle
Rayner really it's just one of these
things where you just kind of have to
take it for what it's worth a lot of
these stories the way they're done
they're not really in continuity they
kind of are where they kind of aren't
it's just a story that's out there
somewhere so you've just got to kind of
take it for what it's worth and just
sort of roll with it but the whole basis
behind the arrival of Salak and these
guys is Salak basically says hey look
there was a freighter that crashed on
Mogo we dropped all these different
xenomorph
off on this planet because it was an
uninhabited world they wouldn't be able
to harm anybody we thought everything
would have been okay and then that
really would have been about in but with
these individuals who have crash-landed
on the planet there's now a dangerous
threat we have to go and deal with it
because we're Green Lantern's and that's
what we do and so of course this leads
to Kyle Rayner basically showing up on
the scene now in the middle of all this
they basically meet a woman named crow
now of course this is our first
indication that not everything is right
here in the sense that crow basically
says hey look these alien things came
out of nowhere they grabbed my crewmates
they didn't want me and they just
whisked off and I have no idea where
they went they went underground in some
big caverns but that's really about it
but what it does is it kind of invokes
this little bit of a creepiness factor
while also dealing with the idea of Kyle
Rayner finding another love interest now
again this is the big deal when it comes
to Colorado for those of guys who were
new when it comes to Kyle he is a guy
that can never find romance right I mean
it's the way it always says every
girlfriend he has dies in some former
fashion sometimes she'll die a hero
other times shota's gets stuffed in a
refrigerator with her you know every
bone in her body broken whatever the
case says he always loses his girlfriend
he can never be happy basically trying
to get with this girl crow it's kind of
funny because he's basically getting all
of his advances rebuked I mean he's
trying to hit on a chick in the worst
situation you could possibly conceive of
to try to hit on a woman but it's still
kind of funny of course in the middle of
exploring the ship there suddenly meant
by the arrival of the Xenomorphs now for
kyle rayner it's quick work I mean it's
creating shields learning to the
Xenomorphs bleed acid trying to get rid
of him and so on and so forth a few of
the members of the of these guys who are
with him are taken in fact everybody but
crow is taken away but for Kyle himself
he's able to roll through them pretty
effectively and it would have to
basically take care of each and every
one of these guys the problem is that in
the middle of all this Kyle loses his
ring and that's where the
where he actually begins to get really
interesting when it comes to the Green
Lanterns they are some of the weakest
beings in existence if they don't have
their rings they're basically just
people they're just regular folks their
own racist when they lose their rings
they're incredibly inept in a lot of
different ways for some people they're
not for like Kilowog for example he's a
pretty beastly guy and he can usually
handle his own but for people like Kyle
Rayner he's an artist I mean the guy
just draws stuff you know and so when he
loses his Lantern ring there's not a
whole lot he can do not will hold on he
can offer this situation but in the end
it does create for some pretty
interesting storytelling because it's
really him alongside salak and the
scroll crow just kind of having to rely
on one another to try to make their way
through and try to get things sorted out
and so again because of the fact there's
not a whole lot there's really not a lot
of meat potatoes going on with this bit
of a story once they do descend down
into the belly of the beast so to speak
they basically come across this sword of
antichamber in the sense that it is the
chamber that leads to where the queen is
at and this whole section is just filled
with the corpses of crew members from
that ship eggs and so on and so forth
par for the course when you're talking
about you know xenomorphs and different
things like that the stuff that we love
to see you know some survivor who's just
like help me you know and the alien
breaks out of his chest and all I got no
story would be complete if we didn't see
a chest burster I love seeing them I
know you love seeing him everybody loves
seeing chest Birch's it is love to see
an alien burst out of a person's chest
it's just it's so captivating it's so
interesting fun fact if you actually go
back and you watch the I want to say
it's the director's cut or special
edition or extended cut or something
like that of the original Ridley Scott
alien movie there is a segment where he
actually intended to basically show what
the life cycle of a xenomorph was that
the xenomorph would basically come from
an egg and then the egg would create a
face hugger it would latch on to a
person it would give birth to an alien
the alien would start grabbing people
and basically converting them into
cocoons and then that would give birth
to more aliens or at least that was the
initial origin now once James Cameron
did aliens - and that introduced the
Queen the whole idea of the organic
matter being converted into a cocoon
that was basically an origin story that
was offered in case of Queens not there
I get it's kind of cool in terms of all
that little history and those little
tidbits and different things like that
but throughout their attempts to make
their way through and find the various
crew mates and the individuals who were
part of the core that Kyle Rayner has
already lost we end up having them
basically stow across the path of the
alien queen so
again things are pretty interesting here
because you're talking about a hulking
beast absolutely massive in size but we
also end up finding out is the reason
why our Raiders ring would not respond
to his commands to summon it was because
of the fact that it was attached to this
resin that the aliens leave behind
whenever it is that they have stuff that
really weird you know sticky stuff that
sounds weird it is one of those
interesting things you know it's one of
those one of those crazy sort of
situations but again much like any of
the other movies that we've seen the
Queen's are highly protective of their
hive and they'll kill anything they see
on sight and that's that's the
interesting thing here is remember the
Queen's are hardcore I mean they're like
queen bees they'll eliminate anything
that's considered to be a possible
threat whether it's actually a threat or
not if it's not familiar it dies but you
know of course with Kyle Rayner and crow
working together the whole idea is okay
well they've already captured salak so
now we have to save him too and so what
they end up doing is they say okay the
Green Lantern ring will be the one thing
that saves our lives if we don't pull
that off we're both going to die here
and so what ends up happening as crow
offers herself as a distraction while
Kyle Rayner races after the ring the
problem with this is that as the
Xenomorphs attack her we end up finding
out she's a robot which is kind of
interesting because that fits in line
with the whole aliens franchise you know
there's always that one member of the
crew who's a robot nobody knew that he
was a robot the whole time but it is
kind of cool
because Kyle Rader of course grabs the
ring and then it's basically Kyle Rayner
against an alien queen and the fight
goes exactly as you would expect how
Rader basically steamrolls this chick
and even like a lot of the Xenomorphs
that are trying to attack him he just
creates like a machine gun
basically just sprays everything down
and that's really about it like he just
obliterates them all it really grabs the
nature of Hal Jordan and the nature of
Kyle Rayner and it really just opposes
the two of them together the logic here
is if Hal Jordan and crew dumped the
Xenomorphs off on you know Mogo under
the idea that it would be a deserted
planet nobody would be able to be harmed
by their presence and then somebody
accidentally crash-landed into it
because her engines were failing and it
was the closest celestial body to them
then the question becomes how often will
that happen are they gonna have to throw
a Green Lantern garrison on Mogo in
order to make sure that anybody who
Stowe's across the path these you know
more Espino will basically be unharmed
than the Xenomorphs to be dealt with
kala later says that's not gonna happen
at all he calls it a day and basically
what he does is he just super charges is
ring emits a violent blast of light and
incinerates every last one of
xeno more sand so grabbing you know
whatever members of the core are left as
well as whatever crews survived the
whole ordeal it really just kind of
wraps up you know it's one of those
things where it's like hey look I mean
you know we made it out and you know now
we're just gonna kind of you know make
our way and hopefully survive and you
know not have to worry about coming back
here to this horrible planet again and
that's really gonna be about it it just
kind of stops I don't know why the
stories in the way they do like this I
mean they don't really wind down it's
just like all right the final battle
done thanks for watching guys peace I
mean that's it's weird how that whole
thing happens but anyway guys but that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explained it make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the
robb cork you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]